monsieur wang à la brian gallant a lancé
sa journée à moncton tout près de
projets de construction routière pour
rappeler que son gouvernement a beaucoup
investis en infrastructures
notre plan d'infrastructure vise visait
à créer des emplois et une économie plus
équitable ce qui a été fait le taux de
chômage est en baisse de 2 points 6 %
depuis notre arrivée au pouvoir il
promet donc d'investir encore davantage
dans ce secteur malgré ceux qui
l'accusent d'être trop dépensier comme
son principal adversaire
les chef progressiste conservateur
brigue a mis le paquet pour démontrer
qu'il a l'intention de se battre pour le
nouveau brunswick
nous ne pouvons nous permettre quatre
années avec regret au pouvoir quatre
autres années de dépenses
blinkx dit vouloir protéger les
entreprises de la province qui perdent
des contrats au profit du québec
comme cette entreprise de produits de
bois où il a choisi de lancer sa
campagne
les cartes de défendre les gens depuis
de nouvelles ont joué la campagne
s'annonce intéressante au nouveau
brunswick parce que les électeurs auront
un véritable choix
les stratégies des partis sont bien
différentes et les chefs le sont tout
autant
brian gallant à 36 ans il est acadien
parfaitement bilingue
l'énigme est d'une autre génération il a
64 ans ancien ministre des finances une
anglophone qui prend des cours de
français mais qui peine encore à
soutenir une conversation dans cette
ligne je pense que l'éducation est
primordiale non seulement d'ailleurs
pour la première fois en près de vingt
ans il n'y aura pas de débat des chefs
en français au nouveau-brunswick
mais biggs a bien proposé quelqu'un pour
le remplacer mais brian gallant insiste
pour que le débat se fasse entre chefs
le débat des chefs en français à radio
canada était mort le mcg a refusé de
débattre en français gallant se cache
derrière la langue pour se trouver une
excuse on verra si au cours des trente
deux prochains jours
le dossier de la langue s'imposera
vraiment comme un enjeu important avec
l'économie dans cette campagne
électorale
ici michel brix de radio canada montrent
les bains actuellement remercie beaucoup